la bandera ucraniana vuelve a ondear en
rue abismo
o bien nuestra querida bandera es uno de
los varios pueblos retomados por el
ejército ucraniano en los últimos días
alrededor de la ciudad dejar que los
oficiales de defensa ucranianos dijeron
que las fuerzas rusas estaban siendo
empujadas fuera la ciudad y sus
alrededores han estado bajo un intenso
ataque desde el inicio de la guerra las
fuerzas armadas de nuestro estado nos
han proporcionado a todos buenas
noticias desde la región dejar que los
ocupantes están siendo gradualmente
alejados de la ciudad
pero las tropas rusas apenas ceden a la
presión están tomando territorio a unos
160 km al sureste del avance ucraniano
hacia partes del donbass que aún están
bajo control de ucrania más al sur el
vital puerto de odessa y la zona de mico
life han sido objeto de intensos
bombardeos en los últimos días el martes
del director de la inteligencia nacional
de eeuu advirtió que no había un final a
la vista
la naturaleza incierta de la batalla que
se está convirtiendo en una guerra de
desgaste combinada con la realidad de
que putin se enfrenta a un desajuste
entre sus ambiciones y las actuales
capacidades militares convencionales de
rusia probablemente significa que los
próximos meses podrían vernos avanzar
por una trayectoria más impredecible
mientras las tropas ucranianas presionan
alrededor de jarquín en el noreste de
ucrania ahora podrían pasar a la
ofensiva y cortar las líneas de
suministros rusas